welcome to this video on playing ice
wide shut from Denmark ice wide shot
this is stanley kubrick movie crew fault
yeah well I was I was thinking about
this movie to be honest and really
forgot what it was this is the one with
the Tom Cruise and Nicole Kidman right
yeah I never really understood this
movie I think I mean compared to two
other Kubrick movies thought it was a
bit strange alright so we have a guru
fault i play this i played this Bishop
e3 Queen d2 line for change hmm 96
that's quite uncommon and so it's it's
believed to be a good for white view hmm
really hmm this is cool I never saw that
one okay Molly threatening bishops III
obviously so I need to react to that
yeah probably just this one general but
this looks like a pretty a pretty nice
position okay let's gain space and then
a c4 even check
yeah my favorite Kubrick movies actually
dr. Strangelove I think I need to
rewatch it I haven't watched it for ages
what's really really great all right so
let's see it's giving me those two pawns
d5 and d5 and yeah okay well if I go
Bishop before you will take it and pin
me on the default so I need to it once
oh yeah he can he can take the spawn
that's that's true okay but I mean those
two bond there should be there should be
worth something something and now all
he's got f6 this is this is some this is
true so is it how should I play the
slope Bishop c4 my king is obviously out
in a bad spot on on 93 how do i how do I
make sure that they have the king yeah I
won't end f60 f6 sm f 6 is a problem so
on f6 i have e 6 m yeah okay come on it
sir it's it doesn't matter other spots
but I need to try to promote my central
pawns came let's go here yeah f5 is an
interesting now
intending Bishop to f6 I looked g1 this
can of the scanned of idea now can well
this is the easy muth try to exchange
that yeah he's obviously willing to to
give an exchange but I wonder yeah
probably i should take the very
important point is that she cannot
really move the porn sign and my king is
sir right in the middle of it check
maybe a bit of a strange a bit of a
strange game but black reason I'm not
not sure at all what what was going on
is probably incorrect what I what I did
but it's not not easy maybe this is
really premature to see five months oh
that's possible yeah here starting here
I probably need to look for some
improvements I mean I don't really
believe that giving up this Ponzi to
assess of any importance but I need to
be precise well rookie won the idea of
rookie one was to support is six and in
case of f6 but maybe I need to go to 2d
one that's that's possible the deep one
obviously is done yeah the pawn that
should promote in the long run
the compounds to play look do you one
yeah but that service is really better
you know yeah well this this is
interesting that it's ultimately risky
ah the comp forgives this is a mistake
and interesting it was to play work the
age and that f6 yeah it's um it's
probably a bit much what I did here but
taking is too risky it says okay all
right evaluates the computer is not
talking we should see form yeah it gives
black only a slight edge here the same
valuation here i'm not sure i know i
mean this is this is something and it's
not difficult to see that the king is
invading now this this is just just
flat-out winning i think yeah no it's no
nothing to do it can cannot prevent my
my king from from invading the general
concept was okay pushing the pawns but I
was probably too quick I think probably
five SS mistimed I need to play some
some prep move cm comp suggest miss
Rooke hg1 and gingi for this is strange
but um yeah or maybe let's say king e to
for example just getting out of this
preparing a possible rook d1 and to
support the center I mean something like
that is probably a bit more precise
alright thanks for watching